my pride is nothing compared to my
kinsmen suffering their eyes were stolen
from every single body all of them
killed for what death creates so I've
sworn to capture the Phantom troupe and
recover the eyes of my clan hello and
welcome to Hunter hunter 101 the series
that breaks down everyone and everything
in the Hunter hunter world today we are
going to be investigating the last
surviving member of the kurta clan guru
Pitka Korra pica is a very reticent yet
extraordinarily intelligent young man
who was first introduced in the series
during the hunter exam Ock he is
presented as quiet and reserved who with
a high degree of analytical ability
although with all of that said it should
also be noted that core pika is very
easily swayed by emotion particularly
that of sadness anger and hatred and you
know what it's pretty hard to blame him
for all of that given his circumstances
Korra picker was born into the Kota clan
located in the Luke sub province and
this group of people were famous for
producing individuals with the ability
to turn their eyes scarlet when they
become emotionally agitated
unfortunately as a result of the
perceived beauty of the scarlet color
these eyes became highly sought after by
flesh collectors and given their rarity
they have sold for amounts ranging from
between nine hundred million to two
billion Jenny throughout the world thus
making Kota clan members a prized
commodity during his adolescence Korra
Pickett was blissfully unaware of this
fact and spent his time studying and
training hard in order to be granted
permission to explore the outside world
but the goal of finding a doctor to heal
his childhood friend Hyrum during this
time was also incur picker first became
aware of the hunter profession after
saving an outsider named Sheila who as
thanks gave Cora pika and Pyrrha a book
detailing the adventures of a
professional hunter which the two
children read religiously eventually
Kirkuk was able to pass all of the tests
required to venture into the outside
world with unrestricted access and so he
set out on his mission to find a doctor
for Pyrrha promising him that he will
return and that the two would venture
out together once he was healed however
six weeks after Cora Pickers departure
an organization known as the Phantom
troupe massacred dakota clan including
Pyrrha and harvested all the scarlet
eyes that they could after discovering
the news her picker filled with profound
anger and despair then vowed to reclaim
all the stolen eyes as well as bring the
phantom troupe to justice in doing so
Cora pika in a sort of twisted manner
decided to pursue he and Pyro's
childhood fantasy of becoming a hunter
although it was not for the sake of
adventure but rather to acquire the
qualifications necessary to make his
revenge mission possible and so as a
result Cora pika became embroiled in the
287 'the hunter exam during this exam he
became entangled with
protagonistic trio of gone lay Oreo and
kilowatt and all four of them went on to
greatly assist one another and a very
lonely career picker even came to
consider them friends a huge step
forward given his state of being at the
time but even with these bonds
developing her picker remained highly
introverted and maintained a singular
focus on his ultimate goal which he took
a step towards by passing the final
phase of the exam and obtaining his
hunter's license however unbeknownst to
quarry picker this was not in fact the
end of the hunter exam and he found
himself unable to acquire work until he
had mastered the basic principles of nen
in this effort he was trained by a
currently unknown hunter who managed to
teach the basic principles of the art
form to core picker within six months
which is particularly incredible
considering that core Pickers individual
known abilities are a bit more complex
than your average user this is because
core pica is a natural Kandra which is a
class that allows its user to create
material objects from their aura
however when quarry picker activates a
scarlet eyes his nen class changes from
Kandra to that of a specialist where the
more curved picker has also gone on to
explore and incorporate elements of
enhancement manipulation and omission
making him one of the most well rounded
known users in the entire series however
his proficiency with in these areas
spawns directly from the fact that he
can become a specialist at will which
grants core picker access to a heart
soon known as Emperor time this allows
Kerr picker to utilize all forms of nen
at 100% efficiency although that maximum
is still limited by his natural
classification as a conjurer so in that
regard
kuri picker will still be outclassed by
any natural master of his lesser
affinities but it does grant him a
preposterous amount of utility in his
own end usage and this has culminated in
the creation of the ultimate weapon
picker picker to wield in his quest to
take revenge on the Phantom troop
essentially it involves a series of five
chains each controlled by one of kirkuk
his fingers on his right hand
each of these chains contains a unique
ability of its own starting with the
dowsing chain in which core picker
conjures a device which can be used to
detect the location of individuals and
even be used to determine whether or not
someone is lying furthermore with
Emperor time active this chain is
enhanced in kirkuk can tell if a person
is lying on a video recording provided
that he has met the individual in
question before next up is change L
which is a binding technique designed to
capture enemies by forcing them into a
state of zetsu thus closing off the
targets aura and forbidding the use of
net so the only way out of the bindings
would be by brute force and well even
that's pretty much impossible however in
the case of change L
core picker has placed a condition on
the techniques usage in order to
increase its potency which is that it
can only be used on a member of the
panting true should Cora pick a break
this condition it would result in his
immediate death then we have holy chain
a combination of conjuration and
enhancement which acts as a basic method
of healing however whilst in his special
estate holy Cheng can heal severe
injuries such as a fractured arm with
India seconds forth on list is judgement
chain a funky combination of conjuration
manipulation and mission where biker
picker penetrates the body of his target
with an end blade known as the steak of
retribution which wraps itself
dangerously around their heart curry
picker is unable to issue his
unfortunate target with up to two
commands and should they disobey the
blade will immediately penetrate their
heart thus killing them quite notably
cur pica has actually used the judgment
chain on himself which was the mechanism
by which he was able to set the
condition for chain Jail although it
should be stated that in order to invoke
the judgment chain Cora picker must
already be using Emperor time due to his
minor affinity in the areas of
manipulation and omission and finally we
have steel chain steel as in ste al
rather than s T WL because this ought to
involves the theft of the nen abilities
of others to do this curve picker
conjures a syringe which once injected
into an opponent will drain their nen
and allow the theft of one of their
abilities rendering the target unable to
use said ability until it is returned to
them to assist with steel chain crew
picker also has a non chain relate to
Tatsu known as stealth dolphin which is
by far one of the most adorably named
nin abilities in the entire series and
it's more of an accessory that allows
him to equip and analyze abilities taken
with steel chain as well as loan those
abilities to others so yes Kurt picker
very rapidly went on to master and
applying an extraordinarily efficiently
to his own personal goals and whilst he
does sound incredibly overpowered at the
moment this usage does come at quite a
hefty cost as to engage in most of his
abilities at maximum potency and for
some of them just at all Cora pick a
must activate Emperor time which drains
his overall lifespan by one hour for
every second he spends in that mode but
in any case after acquiring his nen
arsenal guru Pitka began to seek out the
eyes of his clan and secured a job as a
bodyguard for a flesh collector quite
notably this is where curry pick'em at
melody the music hunter who had become a
close ally via the curt biggest first
task as a bodyguard involved traveling
to york new city and protecting his boss
as he attended an underground auction
now that very same auction would come to
be attacked by the Phantom troupe
leading to a complex series of events in
which Kerr pick' masterfully made use of
his position to commence his vengeance
against the truth this resulted in Kerr
picker managing to kill both of again
and Paco Noda with his judgment chain
ability and furthermore he was also able
to ensnare Chronos
the leader of the Phantom troupe with
the chain as well forbidding krohler
from using men or communicating with
other troupe members singer a pretty
successful first stab at vengeance
against an infamous group of thieves all
of whom possess Class A bounties and yes
Kurt Picard did cater his nobility
specifically to combat the Phantom
troupe however what this conflict shone
a light on most was crew Pickers
phenomenal skill as a master strategist
and a natural-born leader
sadly the whole York New City are also
very much conveyed just how deeply
Kerekes lust for vengeance really is
placing him on a very ruthless and
self-destructive path whereby he
actively isolated himself from his
friends in order to track down the
Scarlet eyes of the Kota clan this
mission consumed him so much that he was
not present for the 13th hunter chairman
election nor did court pick a visit gone
in hospital following the events of the
Chimera ant arc and here's where we're
going to put up a brief spoiler warning
for the events of the manga that have
not yet been animated if you do not wish
to know anything please skip to the
following time but for everyone else
here we go and so our biggest activities
would remain in the background of the
story until he was approached by Miss
ice Tom Nana one of the members of the
zodiacs news ice Tom offered Cora Picard
knowledge regarding the whereabouts of a
large number of scholar ties in exchange
for his assistance accompanying them to
the Dark Continent in doing so Kirkuk
effectively joined the zodiacs obtaining
the codename of rat however enroute to
the Dark Continent Cora picker has now
become embroiled in a deadly succession
war taking place amongst the princes of
the cucking Empire and is currently
serving to protect the fourteenth prince
Wabble some more fun facts about Cora
bicker group occur is thus far the only
character in the entire series who falls
under two natural name categories being
conjuration and specialization via the
use of his scarlet arse
furthermore in addition to his
extraordinary physical and unrelated
abilities her pick is also a master of
general weaponry and has been shown
capable of wielding a bokken knives and
shuriken quite the deadly gent really
among the four main protagonists font
hunter career pika is the only one for
whom we still do not have a full name
and as a result fans have taken to
calling him or to pick a kurta they're
just punking on the name of his clan
speaking of their career pika as with
many many other characters in the series
as an angler - subject to a wide variety
of different romanization 'z ranging
from some basic differences such as
Korra pika with a C rather than a K at
the end to the truly mind-boggling
Kirara picked which comes to us rather
sadly courtesy of the official Hunter
hunter Dada book correct has maintained
a consistent streak of popularity during
the entire run of hunt
Hunter having secured the second place
position in all three character
popularity polls conducted bike weekly
shonen job however it has been noted
that during the first poll many fans
were quite confused about his gender
which allegedly led him to receiving
many many many points and finally a
truly useless fact despite the fact that
career picker was too earrings
throughout the entirety of the series
only one has ever been shot well except
for the 1999 anime version where they
displayed both but only once but that
pretty much does it for Korra picker if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the New
World review patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
spot this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan me takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured on the next Hunter hunter 101
and as for the final skill which I did
not mention get this kora pika is so
incredible that he is capable of holding
two trays of green things at the same
time Wow